la parole est à d'autres collègues
antoine lefèvre pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre l'enfer est
pavé de bonnes intentions écrivait
bernard de clairvaux le bouclier
tarifaire appliquée pour contenir la
hausse du prix du gaz est quant à lui
une véritable bombe à retardement pour
nos concitoyens les plus démunis mise en
place dans la loi de finances 2022 pour
geler l'augmentation des tarifs gaziers
jusqu'au 1er juillet ce dispositif offre
une couverture louable face à
l'augmentation de la demande mondiale et
la restriction de l'offre il ne
s'applique toutefois qu aux habitations
individuelles ou collectives
justifiant d'une consommation inférieure
à 150 mégawatts heure est doté d'un
contrat réglementé gaz bay un des
critères auxquels ne répondent
malheureusement pas les bailleurs
sociaux chargés d'acheter le gaz en
amont avant de les redistribuer à leurs
locataires les organismes hlm vont ainsi
subir de plein fouet la hausse des
tarifs et n'auront d'autre choix que de
répercuter celle ci sur les factures de
leurs locataires je ne parle pas ici
d'augmentation de quelques euros à la
marge mais bel et bien de hausse pouvant
s'échelonner de 40 à 250 euros de
provisions de charges supplémentaires
par mois et ce jusqu'à la fin de la
saison de chauffe une ironie des plus
mordante lorsque l'on fait état des
engagements pris par votre gouvernement
pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
français
la question monsieur le premier ministre
est donc la suivante dans quel délai
comptez vous revenir sur ce dispositif
qui s'il n'est pas rectifié de façon
rétroactive risque de mettre une fois de
plus à l'amande aux concitoyens les plus
fragiles je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est à la glisse
délégué en charge du logement madame
d'argon
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur antoine lefèvre vous l'avez dit
nous avons sans attendre pris des
mesures fortes pour protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des français face à cette
augmentation importante des prix de
l'énergie on peut parler du chaque
énergie 100 euros pour 6 millions de
ménages qui s'ajoute aux 150 euros
versés normalement en mai on peut par
des l'indemnité inflation 100 euros pour
38 million de ménages qui vont voir leur
pouvoir d'achat soutenu ainsi et nous
avons effectivement décidé c'est une
mesure nationale très forte
gelé les tarifs réglementés de
l'électricité en les plafonnant à + 4 %
et de geler les tarifs du gaz la
question que vous posez concerne les
ménages qui n'achètent pas directement
la gaze à un fournisseur à tarif
réglementé mais qui sont dans des
contrats collectifs en particulier ceux
qui sont souscrits par les organismes de
logements sociaux ces organismes de
logements sociaux nous ont effectivement
fait part il y a quelques jours à peine
de difficulté sachant qu'ils ne sont pas
tous dans cette situation certains sont
chauffés à l'électricité au réseau de
chaleur certains sont avec des contrats
individuels pour les locataires qui sont
donc bien protégés certains achètent
eux-mêmes en contrats collectifs le gaz
et ses contrats collectifs sont dans un
certain nombre de cas eux-mêmes protéger
parce qu'un d'excès sur les tarifs
réglementés et dans d'autres cas non sur
tous les sujets qui nous sont remontés
ces les situations de défaillances de
fournisseurs de logement social
fournisseur de gaz qui n'étant plus en
capacité de fournir demande aux
organismes de logement social de trouver
un autre fournisseur et dans ce cas là
on est au prix du marché face à cette
situation bien sûr le gouvernement va
continuer à travailler pour améliorer
encore la protection des français c'est
un dossier qui est partagé entre bruno
le maire barbara pompili et moi même
nous sommes en train de regarder sous
l'égide du premier ministre toutes les
solutions possibles pour que nous
puissions protéger tous les français
quel que soit leur statut au regard de
leur logement
monsieur lefebvre
oui merci madame la ministre qualifié ce
problème de malencontreux oubli serait
un bel euphémisme pour que compass pour
coupe pour peu pardon que l'on passe en
revue les cinq dernières années de
négligence à l'égard du logement social
entre les coupes budgétaires opérées
trois années de suite le doublement de
la tva sur la construction de logements
sociaux la très controversée réduction
des apl le ralentissement sans précédent
du rythme de construction et
dernièrement la désindexation du plafond
de ressources pour bénéficier d'une
réduction de loyer de solidarité nous
savions que les maisons individuelles et
est devenu un non sens écologique
désormais madame la ministre et
l'habitat collectif à loyer modéré qui
en prend pour son grade décidément il ne
sera pas exagéré de dire que tout au
long de ce quinquennat le gouvernement a
eu un sacré problème avec le logement
social
merci
[Musique]
pour